I let's not go to to central London and
join at Nick Clegg go this morning Mr
Clegg and this inquiry well it's
exonerated Lord Renard really and they
say there's no proof beyond reasonable
doubt why is that not good enough for
you well the report that you're allude
to which was published last week by a QC
Alastair Webster following a long
punctilious look at all of this said
firstly you're quite right that there
was not sufficient evidence to suggest
beyond reasonable doubt that in effect a
criminal offence had been committed but
there was evidence to show that real
distress had been caused amongst the
women in question by Lord run Reynolds
behaviour and so this QC made the
recommendation that in the light of that
Lord Rennard should do the decent thing
which is simply to apologize and reflect
on his behavior so it doesn't happen
again you've been exercised little he
says he's denied all this and if he says
look I've done nothing wrong if you were
in that position and you just you
genuine believed you did nothing wrong
why would you say sorry well because the
person who following a long formal / set
process has been asked to look into this
independently the QC said that whilst in
effect a criminal offence had not been
committed distress have been caused and
that just as in you know any other walk
of life when you cause distress to
somebody else even if you have different
motives or you do it inadvertently you
should apologize that seems to me to be
the basic decent thing to do and I think
many people looking at this program now
now would know that you know in life in
everyday life or countless occasions
when people do or say things to other
people regardless for their motives that
caused offence and distress and which
then require an apology and that is what
i want to see now happen I don't think
Lord when I should rejoin the party in
the House of Lords until that apology
has been issued so what happens if he
turns up there today does it all kick
off what happens what clearly if he if
he decides to
not only ignore my views but that of the
independent report produced at the end
of a formal process the view of many
other liberal democrats perhaps most
importantly the i think just also
defying common basic decency of
apologizing when when distress has been
caused in in in other people i think if
you were to do that well clearly matters
would not rest there but i don't think
it needs to get to that if only he would
respond to the clear recommendation made
as I say in a report by an independent
QC following on bernal okay and if it
does look at all of this and if it
doesn't get to that and not only will he
have defied in your view basic decencies
also define you is easy not and and if
he defies you has he had his chips look
I don't want you know what I want him to
do is to do the decent thing I'm the
leader of a political party I'm not the
lead of us leader of a sect I can't I
can't I can't frog-march someone to
polarize in apps you refuse to do it but
I can be very clear in my strongly held
views which is firstly as leader I've
got a duty of care to those women who
for whom who have experienced that
distress secondly to uphold the the the
process the formal process which has led
to this suggestion that an apology
should be made and thirdly and most
importantly to communicate loud and
clear that in the party I lead I expect
people to treat other people and by the
way particular people in a position of
authority should should should treat
other people with civility with respect
and with dignity that did not happen
here well then that is why I think it is
right that an apology should be issued
well do you know more than the enquiry
knows then I mean in your view is is he
a dirty old man then now all I know is
what you must don't worry but introduces
and you can read no no all I'm all I'm
going by is the conclusions were arrived
at by this independent QC last week who
said that whilst the evidence was not
sufficient to show beyond reasonable
doubt that in effect a criminal offense
had been committed nonetheless distress
had been caused and that merited an
apology that's what he said and I think
it is right
that Lord Reynaud now does the decent
thing and apologizes to those people
who'd suffered that distress but I
suppose I mean there's a this was like
sport i'd say they're a goal or it's not
a goal across the line or it didn't
cross the line it was handball or it
wasn't and the referee says it wasn't so
if you don't like what this referee is
said and you don't give any goal line
technology do you want to rehearing on
this I want as I say for Lord Rennard to
apologize if he doesn't apologize to be
done so that'll be does not look an you
do anything about it if he doesn't well
if he if he doesn't then then of course
there are more things that can be done
and and the party war then I have to
take further action but I really do
think for many people outside politics
and outside the arcane rules that are
can place the house and laws most people
understand that sorry is not always a
word that you're instructed to to to
utter by a a a court of law it is saying
you do if you have anything on you just
cause distress amongst other people so
Mr Clegg you just stopped in short of
you knew you say other things will
happen is it inevitable that he's out
that he's history can you make it happen
can the House of Lords make it happen
can the liberal peers make it happen and
if he doesn't apologize is he aight yes
or no of course there are a range of
options available to the party if he
does rejoin the Lord's parliamentary
party this afternoon without apologizing
but I hope it won't come to that I hope
you'll either apologize or if he doesn't
not rejoin the party in the House of
Lords that's what I want so he is going
to be history if he doesn't say sorry I
would take it at from that you may not
say that but that earlier assuming no
yes I just thought you're asking me to
your asked me to look at this or next
turn of the wheel when I hope we can now
bring these things to a satisfied not a
satisfactory but at least bring them to
a close by Lord Rennard simply doing
what he was asked to do in this in this
report produced independently after a
long formal process which is which is
now being a on for several months but
very few of you do what you're asked to
do and I've asked your number of times
just as he history Ozzie not and you're
saying clearly might be over it's quite
obvious you would like them
to be history though I mean if you had
your way you'd Buddha Mike would you
well you're asked me what I would like
in the future in a slightly different
set of something what I like now is for
him to apologize has been asked to and
not to rejoin the party in the House of
Lords if he doesn't apologize for the
for the reasons that I think many people
in this program would watching this
program would understand which is that
regardless of whether you are shown to
caused in effect a criminal offense or
not if you have caused offense and
distress yeah in other individuals the
you know basic human decency suggests in
politics is in as in normal everyday
life that you apologize for that